it's the most infamous Paradox in all of
logic the Paradox of the liar or the
self-referential statement which asserts
its own falsehood
to most this Paradox is a clever But
ultimately empty surface tree lacking in
any real content or significance
but few are aware How Deeply this
Paradox lies at the heart of a number of
famous incompleteness theorems that have
emerged out of mathematics and logic
over the last century
indeed is this Paradox actually much
stronger than most people think
or is the liar still playing us all for
a fool
this is dialect with
the strengthened liar and paradoxes of
incompleteness
[Music]
for a minute let's compare and contrast
two similar sentences
one this statement is untrue
and two this statement is unprovable
now but for a single word these two
sentences are exactly alike and indeed
they both appear to contain similar
paradoxical head scratching implications
most of us are familiar with the first
one which is commonly known as the
Liar's Paradox and we don't think it's a
stretch to say that if asked the average
person isn't likely to say that this
statement carries any real significance
the Paradox is clever and fun perhaps
But ultimately Common Sense tells us
it's just a silly self-referential play
on words
the second sentence on the other hand is
widely regarded as anything but trivial
it is in fact responsible for a
multitude of Sensational sounding
theorems that have come out of
mathematics logic and computability over
the last century
the results of these theorems the most
famous of which are girdles in
completeness theorem tarsky's
undefinability theorem and turing's
halting problem purportedly tell us that
we can never have a complete system of
mathematics formal logic or
computability respectively
that is that there will always be
statements that are true Within These
systems but not provable
now Popular Science loves to take these
theorems and run wild with them that are
impossible one need only glance at
highly successful YouTube titles like
these to see what sort of conclusions
the theorems can inspire
Additionally you can find the idea of
incompleteness being used to explain
Mysteries as far ranging as the nature
of consciousness
quantum physics
free will
or even life itself
sometimes to Pulitzer prize-winning
effect
while those who have studied the subject
are generally quick to assure you that
incompleteness doesn't mean all that
what exactly it does mean is also
something they typically have difficulty
expressing
and usually you'll get a regurgitation
of the aforementioned statement that is
that there are additional true
statements in the system that are not
provable
but does that statement in itself
actually mean anything at all
often when confronted with dubious
interpretations of an esoteric work
it's best to go to the very Source
itself
in this case we may not yet possess the
tools to tackle girdle's proof head on
but we can make a number of strong
inferences based on an informal summary
girdle himself provides us with in the
opening passages of his work
here indeed girdle tells us that his
theorem has a close relationship to the
Liar's paradox
but what does that mean
well in the next few lines girdle writes
that as a result of his formal
constructions we are confronted with a
proposition that asserts its own
unprovability
so when he says his theorem and the liar
Paradox are closely related
he's indicating that they're literally
the same thing but with the word untrue
swapped for unprovable
of course in order to build this liar
statement in formal terms girls proof
utilizes a ton of impressive machinery
girdle numbering diagonalization and all
that
but as girdle writes in the closing
lines of his introduction
it's the liar statement itself
and the contradiction that it furnishes
that allows him to reach his famous
conclusion regarding the existence of
undecidable statements in mathematics
[Music]
meaning of a sentence doesn't change
simply because one chooses to express it
in French rather than in English
similarly it should be clear that the
significance of a sentence like this
statement is unprovable shouldn't change
simply because we choose to express it
via a very carefully constructed
mathematical language rather than in
colloquial speak
but this naturally begs the question if
Common Sense tells us the Liar's Paradox
isn't anything significant in everyday
language why the heck does it suddenly
become so significant when it's
translated into a mathematical
computable or logical language
indeed there seem to be several routes
to answering this question depending on
one's belief about what girdle's proof
actually signifies
the first route is to assert a
significance in the distinction between
the everyday notion of Truth versus the
mathematical notion of provability
to us such a distinction is superficial
and doesn't hold up to deeper analysis
but regardless one can easily recast the
Liar's Paradox in terms that don't
invoke the concept of true and false
such as with the Nelson grilling paradox
or the barber paradox
indicating we can't attribute the
significance of incompleteness solely to
the distinction between true and
provable
another route to take is via historical
context wherein we recognize that
girdle's incompleteness theorem was a
reaction to the Hilbert program of the
early 20th century
a program which basically treated math
like a religion and assumed that all
mathematical truths could be constructed
out of a few simple ones
by showing that an absurd
self-referential statement could be
constructed in almost solely
mathematical terms one could argue that
girdle was cleverly demonstrating that
mathematics was merely a language like
any other and therefore subject to all
of its usual foibles
but this answer overlooks one crucial
and hugely problematical point
in order to believe in the results of
girdle's theorem that is in order to be
able to conclude that mathematics is
incomplete we have to first believe that
the sentence this statement is
unprovable is truly paradoxical and not
simply a gibberish nonsensical statement
disguised as a well-formed one
which means the validity of every
incompleteness theorem boils down to
whether or not you believe the sentence
this statement is unprovable is truly a
valid paradox
the renowned logician Alfred tarsky
understood this quite straightforwardly
and his conclusion was that this meant
that the Liar's Paradox was something
extremely significant
to depreciate the importance of this and
other antinomies he wrote in his works
and to treat them as jokes or
sophistries would be quite wrong and
dangerous from the standpoint of
scientific progress
of course since his own cherished
undefinability theorem hinges on the
Liar's Paradox it's hard not to read a
certain measure of bias in this
statement
moreover he never qualifies it with any
explanation of specifically why or how
failing to take the Liar's Paradox
seriously would present such a danger to
science
indeed you'd be hard-pressed to say that
the average person would adopt a stance
such as tarsky's since no empirical
content could ever be found within a
sentence such as this statement is false
our ordinary intuition tends to reject
it as a case of trivial semantics
but if we reject our everyday notion of
the Liar's Paradox then we must reject
any notion of the liar statement
regardless of how formally or
intelligently it may be codified
this would of course render the liar
statements as constructed by girdle
Turing and tarsky to be nothing more
than cases of trivial semantics from
which no real deductions or conclusions
could ever be drawn
to attempt to rescue the significance of
self-referential liar statements we can
however take refuge in what's known as
the strengthened liar
sometimes also called the Liar's Revenge
what is the strengthened liar
well as opposed to a sentence that goes
this statement is false the strengthened
liar instead reads this statement is not
true
it's an Ever So slight difference in
semantic construction small enough at
first glance as to seem entirely
pointless
but it's actually intended to
incorporate the neither true nor false
resolutions that are typically offered
up in response to the Liar's paradox
that is when we are confronted with the
statement this statement is false
we can't navigate our way to a
resolution unless we claim that the
notion of true or false can't be applied
to it
and that rather some third intermediate
value should be assigned as the
paradox's outcome for example
indeterminate meaningless undecidable
Etc
but with this statement is not true the
category not true now encompasses the
possibility that this statement if not
false can instead be indeterminate or
whatever third value we've chosen to
assign to it
thus if we repeat the Paradox we'll see
that while interpreting the statement as
false still produces a contradiction
interpreting the statement as true
doesn't lead to the implication that the
statement must be false rather the
statement can still be our third
indeterminate value
meaning no contradiction results and
there is no paradox
thus when we construct the strengthened
liar we are in essence building a
solution to the traditional liar Paradox
that asserts this statement is not true
is true because it is indeterminate
in essence we've discovered a truth that
lies outside the domain of empirical
content
but of course this is a completely
trivial truth since all it says is that
we have a gibberish meaningless
statement before us
now Swap this statement is not true for
this statement is not provable and we
can repeat the strengthened liar
argument to reach a conclusion that goes
this statement is not provable is true
because it is indeterminate
therefore we have shown that there are
statements within our system of
reasoning which are true but not
provable
in other words we've just recreated the
only precise meaning one can give to the
incompleteness theorems
but of course we see this is only
because those statements which are true
but not provable are in fact only
statements about the meaninglessness of
other statements
which brings us in all likelihood to
what girdles and the other
incompleteness theorems are truly about
finding ways to construct undefined or
underdefined statements that have the
appearance of being well defined
and then applying the strengthened liar
to them in order to deduce a truth that
doesn't arise from the axioms
namely that those statements are
undefined
but wait you might object isn't all the
rigor and structure of girdle's proof
exactly meant to prevent one from coming
up with an undefined or underdefined
statement in the first place
well that's the million dollar question
one possible answer is no not
necessarily girdle tarsky and others
were partially concerned with giving
classification to the relative strengths
of formal languages and when and how
they would or wouldn't lead to
paradoxical self-referential statements
so their proofs could mean that at a
certain level of logical language
adoption you're always going to be able
to sneak in undefined Concepts into your
structure
or there's the chance that girdle's
construction itself is flawed
many have suggested this possibility
over the decades and indeed the
theorem's close resemblance to another
Paradox known as Richard's Paradox
suggests this may well be the case as
Richard's Paradox itself was said by its
own inventor not to be a valid or
well-defined one
but all of this of course requires much
more investigation so we'll be following
up with it in future videos
in the meantime we want to know your
thoughts on incompleteness
do you truly believe these theorems to
be immensely profound statements about
our reality or are they a case of over
inflating something that is utterly
trivial
no one but you can ultimately form that
opinion so think on it carefully
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
[Music]